[Musik]
gespenstische leere im zweitgrößten
frachtflughafen deutschlands seit dem 25
märz ist der flughafen leipzig halle
durch die korona krise von regulären
linienflügen abgekoppelt die hoffnung
lag auf mitte juni den flugbetrieb
wieder aufzunehmen alles ist für die
flugpassagiere vorbereitet automaten mit
masken desinfektionsmittel abgeklebte
abstand neu gestellte security reihen
doch die lufthansa sieht das anders
leipzig sei aus operationellen und
wirtschaftlichen gründen nicht
ansteuerbar
der flug krise entschied sich für den
airport dresden und somit für den
direkten konkurrenten
der passagierverkehr ist gestern in
dresden auf ganz kleiner flamme wieder
angelaufen euro plan 5 x vision die
straßen mid düsseldorf zu verbinden auch
die lufthansa hat angekündigt dresden
hat mitte juni wieder mit frankfurt zu
verbinden
informationen zum flughafen leipzig
halle liegen da noch nicht vor
dementsprechend würde ich jeden
passagier bitten sich direkt mit seiner
fluggesellschaft oder mit seinem
reiseveranstalter in verbindung zu
setzen ab wann denn flüge wieder
durchgeführt werden
ein erster wichtiger schritt ist gerade
geschehen ist wurde die reisewarnung für
31 europäische länder aufgehoben
nichtsdestotrotz bis es so der flughafen
ist eine infrastruktur die auch in der
krise betriebsbereit machen bleiben den
leipzigern weiterhin nur die frachtflüge
und privat jets man hier wieder
touristen an und abfliegen können
[Musik]